やっべえ、最近全然Twitter読んでなかった。
「今日買ってきました！」
あ！
あの、はじめしゃちょーの漫画の第4巻が出てますね。
買ってきてくれてありがとうございます<m(__)m>
面白いんで是非読んでみてください。多分ね本屋さんに売ってると思う。
「何してるの？」（twitterの投稿）
今、動画撮ってます。
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです！
今日はですね、ちょっと皆さんに質問というか、お話…
ちょっと全然頭が見切れてんな。
今日はですね、皆さんに少し……。ご相談というか
ちょっとね、どうすりゃいいんだろうと思ってる事があって
ちょっと、聞いてみたいと思います。
あのー…。静岡で生活して早何年だろ……。
18歳の時に来たから…。
21、22、23、24、25…！
もう7年も静岡にいるわけですよ？！
ヤバっ…
もうこんだけ長い時間静岡にいると、やっぱり静岡の居心地が良すぎて
もう、静岡しか考えれんねーなって思っちゃったんですけど
以外と世の中そうじゃねえなって最近思う事がありまして
やっぱね、結局なんやかんや東京に行くことが多いんですよ。
きっとこの先も多いと思うんで、んー、やっぱね
この家も良いし、大家さんも良いんですけど
もし仮にですよ？！もし仮に！
これ以上があるとは思って無いんですけど、もし仮にこれ以上良い場所が…
東京により近くて、すぐ行けるような場所が
そして、動画が撮りやすい環境がもしあったら
めちゃくちゃ良いな、と思いまして。
もうそこには、もう引っ越すしかねえなって思っちゃったんですよ。
あればですけどね？
皆さん………………………。
良いとこないですか？
ちょっとでもね、理想がなーでかいんだよなー。
とりあえず、もしね次ね、引っ越しするとしたらね
庭付きで、あってほしい。
でっかい家とかで動画とか撮りたいんで何か庭付きの物件だったら良いなっていう感じです。
外で撮影して、外で何か目立った事すると、凄い…
盗撮とかね、こう人が来ちゃって、もう普通だとできないんすよね。
で、普通だとできない外での撮影をできるように、大きな庭が欲しいなとか思ったりしてるんですけど
そういう物件があればな～、って良いな～と思っちゃって。
そこ＋やっぱ大事なのは
東京への近さ
静岡からだと、大体1時間半以上かかるんで
1時間…以内とかに着けたらめちゃくちゃ良いなとか思ったりしてて
何処が良いんだろっていうのちょっと分かんないんでちょっと…
調べよ！！
はい。では探していきましょう。今俺どこにいるんだろう自分の現在地が‥
あやべ、住所出ちゃう住所出ちゃう！！
やべ、ばりばり住所出ちゃうじゃんこれ
辛っ！辛っ！
もうもうざっくりもういいや。
まあ、ざっくりというとね、えー…。僕は今
ざっくり日本でいうと僕は今、ここらへんにいるわけですよ。
東京までね、結構でもね、思ったより近いんすよね。
静岡っていうのはホントに良い場所で、東京近いじゃん？
んで名古屋も近いやん？
日本地図を離してみると、割とね
おっとぉ～
ウラジオストク （ロシア語：Владивосток ヴラヂヴァストーク、IPA:[vlədʲɪvɐˈstok]、ru-Vladivostok.ogg 発音[ヘルプ/ファイル]；ラテン文字表記の例: Vladivostok、漢語: 海参崴）は、ロシアの極東部に位置する都市で、沿海地方（プリモールスキイ地方、Приморский край）の州都である。
日本の真ん中なんですよね。静岡が。
だからどこにでもね、行きやすいっちゃ行きやすいっていう絶妙なポジションに実は住んでおります。
で、こっから東京に近づくとなるとまず…
ま、名古屋浜松方面は無いとして、
神奈川
千葉
東京
山梨
埼玉
群馬
栃木
茨城
（神奈川、千葉、東京、山梨、埼玉、群馬、栃木、茨城）あたりかなとかは思っちゃったりしてます。
それか
箱根とか、神奈川とかかな。そこらへんも良いんだよな～
とりあえず、東京付近で何か良い場所は無いかな～と思ってるんですよね～
千葉とかありなんだよな。実際。
熱海もありやな～。
小田原、熱海当たりとか結構、結構良いかなと思いつつ
東京付近だと、やっぱり埼玉とかも良いんだよな～
地元の富山に帰る作戦もありだと思うんですけども、
富山から、東京行くってなると
こう、ぐわぁ～っと行って、糸魚川行っっって
新潟入っちゃって、このままぶわっと下りて
長野を超えて、高崎、群馬とか行って
がぁっと下りて下りて下りて
練馬区…？そして東京に着くという流れなんで
遠くなっちゃうわけなんすよ。
なんで、富山に帰るっていう線は、今の所ちょっと無いかなとは今の所思っております。
うん…。とりあえず条件としては、東京になるべく、今いる家よりかは近い方が良いかなと思っております。
東京でしょ…？何かね、海沿いのねオーシャンビューとか、良いなって思っちゃうんですよね。
宮川区（？）とか無いかなっ？
東京ディズニーシー（東京ディズニーシー（とうきょうディズニーシー、英称:Tokyo DisneySea、略称:TDS）は、東京ディズニーランド (TDL) などと共に東京ディズニーリゾート (TDR) を形成する、7つのエリアで構成されるディズニーパーク。）ですね
東京ディズニーシーの近くに住むっていうのも作戦的にはありですな
あぁ～、でもな～。高そうだな～。
ちょっと、都心はやめておこうかな…っと
大江戸温泉物語だ！！
何かその東京の真ん中だと多分ね、庭付きの大きな家とか無いと思うんで
ん～、やっぱちょっと下がってな…、神奈川とか結構実際ありな気がするんだよな…
江の島！！
行った事ないから行ってみたいんすよね…
いや、箱根とかってさ実際どうなんすかね
小田原…。ほらっ！小田原とかね結構ありだと思うんですよ。
だから、今住んでるところと東京のさらに間なんで
ま、近いっちゃ近い。車でも行けそう。電車でも新幹線でも行けそうな距離ではあります。
小田原にしようかな……。
これ、逆に回っちゃって何か、筑波とかさ、埼玉とかに行っちゃうっていう作戦もあるし
まあ、そういう山梨とかに逃げちゃっても良い気もします。
ちょっとねまだ分かんないな～。
はい、という感じで実はですね
別に、引っ越ししようとしてる訳じゃ無いんですけども
距離が近くなって、まあ今より何かいい感じだったら別に僕は引っ越しても良いのかなとは思っております。
ただな～…。
もう、引っ越したくないんですよね正直
もう、この家がホントに良すぎて！！
良すぎだし、大家さんも良い人すぎて、もう出たくないんですよ～（泣
ただたんに東京への距離が遠いだけなんですぅ～（泣
でも、もうホントにね～
底を削るしか無いなとは思っているんで
何処が良いんでしょうね？？
場所的に良い所があったら、ホントに何かそこら辺の物件とか調べたいなとは思っているんですけども～
分かんねえな、でも引っ越せたらいいなっていう気がしてます。
ヤバいなぁ。
俺もいよいよ静岡を離れる時が近づいているのかもしれない！！
分かんないですけど。
いいとこが見つかんなかったら、ホント僕はここが一番良いと思ってるんで
良い場所があったら教えて下さい。
いやでも出たくないんだよなぁ～、もうどっちなんだよってね☆
（謎の間）
カァァァッッッ（唐突
いや、まずね何県に住むかを決めたいんだよな。
お勧めの県とか場所があったら教えて下さい。
なるべく東京に近かったら
嬉しいなっ♪
じゃあなっ！！
字幕担当：うめうさｐ　　作成時間約1時間
2月18日の格言（http://iyashitour.com/meigen/theme/life/5）より
人生に失敗した人の多くは、
諦めたときに自分がどれほど成功に近づいていたか
気づかなかった人たちだ。
-　トーマス・エジソン　-
（米国の発明家、起業家 / 1847～1931）　Wikipedia
2018年2月18日0:10分現在のニュース（Yahooニュースより）
在英のシリア人権監視団は17日、トルコ軍などが16日にシリア北部アフリン近郊を砲撃し、その後6人が呼吸困難を訴えて病院に運ばれたと明らかにした。
患者の症状から毒ガスが使用された疑いが出ている。
AFP通信によれば、患者は搬送先で酸素マスクを着け、意識がもうろうとした状態。治療に当たる医師は「せきが出て、全身の皮膚が赤くただれている。衣服を保存して調べる」と話した。
トルコ外交筋はシリア人権監視団の発表について「根も葉もない言い掛かりだ。われわれは市民に対し細心の注意を払っている」と述べ、毒ガス使用を否定した。
トルコは1月にシリア領内へ越境攻撃を仕掛け、クルド人勢力と交戦を続ける。2月初旬にはクルド人民兵組織に参加したクルド人女性兵士が戦死し、遺体が侮辱される動画が拡散するなど、トルコ軍やトルコの支援を受ける武装勢力による人権侵害への懸念も強まっている。